حصيله ضحايا الصراع في السودان ارتفع
الثلاثه اضعاف مقارنه بالاسابيع الاولى من
النزاع والارقام الصادره صادمه وفق بيانات
منظمه النزاع المسلح
اكثر من
1800 قتيل بعد شهر ونصف على بدايه الصراع
الدائر منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل وتتحدث
الارقام المهوله عن دفن 180 شخصا مجهولي
الهويه في الخرطوم ودارفور اما عدد
المفقودين منذ بدايه الحرب فبلغ
283 حتى الان على وقع معارك عنيفه
بالاسلحه الثقيله والقصف الجوي بين جيش
والدعم السريع الارقام الامميه اكدت ايضا
فرار قرابه 200 الف شخص من السودان ونزوح
اكثر من 700 الف شخص اما المعركه الام
فتتركز في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حيث
بلغت نسبه حوادث العنف السياسي
60% منذ بدايه الصراع محاسن حضاره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات